[Musique]
soyez les bienvenus dans le débat de
france 24 un triste spectacle c'est ce
qui pourrait résumer la finale de la
ligue des champions la fiche était
pourtant belle liverpool real madrid la
suite les témoins dans nine street se
dit extrêmement déçu aujourd'hui par le
traitement réservé aux supporters
anglais le premier ministre britannique
dénonce le premier ministre français lui
dénonce une fraude massive de faux
billets à trente à quarante mille faux
tickets ont circulé ce soir là selon
gérald arman alors pourquoi de tels
dysfonctionnements
à qui la faute comment éviter d'autres
fiasco à l'avenir voilà autant de
questions que nous posons à nos invités
bonsoir à vous xavier barret êtes
consultant un sport merci d'avoir
accepté l'invitation de france 24 à vos
côtés jean christophe vix bonsoir à vous
êtes secrétaire national du syndicat
unité sgp police fo merci d'avoir
accepté l'invitation de france24
également rodolfo amaya bonsoir et
bienvenue sur france24 président du club
officiel des supporters de liverpool en
france vous y étiez présent au match ce
soir là on va devenir ensemble sur votre
récit à vous et puis patrick mignon
bonsoir à vous vous êtes sociologue vous
êtes ancien chercheur à l'insep puis
vous vous êtes énormément pencher sur
ces questions de de la culture du
supporting si on peut le dire comme ça
on va y revenir merci à tous les 4
gérald darmanin a donné une conférence
de presse cet après midi aux côtés de la
ministre des sports le ministre de
l'intérieur et qui continue de dénoncer
la circulation de milliers de faux
billets 30000 à 40000 il a parlé de
fraudes massives industrielle même on va
l'écouter et puis vous fait réagir juste
après ce qui a été constaté c'est une
fraude massive
industriel est organisé de faux billets
puisque les prêts filtrage évoquée par
les stadiers par le stade de france la
fédération française de football prévoit
plus de 70% de faux billets à l'entrée
du stade de france puis une fois passé
ce prêt filtrage il a été constaté plus
de 15% de faux billets également
après les premiers prêts filtrage puis
c'est à dire plus de 2600 chiffre
confirmé par l'uefa de billets non
validées alors même qu'ils avaient passé
le premier filtrage voilà pour l'extrait
de cette conférence de presse rodolfo
amaya le ministre de l'intérieur n'a pas
seulement présenter des excuses et ce
qu'ils auraient dû le faire tout de même
pour les supporters de liverpool pointé
du doigt dès le début de cette soirée je
trouve que le traitement qui est de
donner à nos supporteurs et
triste et très très triste parce qu'en
plus d'avoir été bousculé ensuite
malmené par par des des personnes mal
intentionnées à la sortie du stade il se
retrouve accusé de ces mêmes ces mêmes
problèmes qu'ils n'ont pas créée ils
sont tout simplement venus profiter
d'une belle fête sportive il y a eu des
faux billets qui ont circulé ce soir là
il y avait des faux tickets même si le
chiffre peut être contesté 30000 à 40000
ça semble énorme mais ce qu'il y avait
des faux billets vous qui étiez présent
ce soir là est ce que vous l'avez
constaté
j'ai constaté des personnes qui en
arrivant au premier contrôle comme
disait le ministre se sont vus
refuser l'entrée et la protestation que
je trouve tout à fait naturel dans ce
cas là si on en a payé une bonne petite
fortune pour pour ces sésames la
protestation ne durerait pas plus de 30
45 secondes et après demi tour et au
revoir jean christophe bouvier on a vu
certaines séquences où les forces de
l'ordre ont eu recours à du gaz
lacrymogènes parfois des enfants parfois
des femmes en simple parfois des
supporters relativement calme est ce
qu'il y a eu en usage disproportionné la
force ce soir là alors en fait il faut
bien il faut bien j'allais dire séparé
en deux deux actes le premier acte
effectivement on a affaire l'uefa et un
consortium privé donc c'est à eux de
gérer l'événement c'est à eux de gérer
la sécurité ça veut dire et le filtrage
etc c'est à dire donc de déployer des
stadiers 1700 à prioriser mis 700
stadiers 1700 personnes le sécurité pour
gérer j'allais dire l'ensemble du
dispositif et la police une prestation
de sécurité qui est payé c'est le
prestataire qui paye les policiers et
nous on est là en plus pour intervenir
s'il ya d'effectivement d
des heures tout comme on a pu le voir
donc en fait vous donner après lorsqu'on
fait du ont fait du qu'on appelle ça du
statique voyez on se met en évidence
pour montrer qu'à de la police mais en
fait c'est pas à nous de vérifier les
billets c'est pas nous de faire du
filtrage c'est vraiment privé et donc on
nous interpelle on nous dit voilà vie
devenait parce qu'on est dépassée parce
qu'il ya des émeutes parce que
effectivement il ya des personnes qui
auraient des faux billets qui sont
devant les entrées les tourniquets de
certaines entrées du stade et qui
empêche les autres aussi de passer et on
voit bien qu'elles ont donnée ça
s'énerve ça commence à bousculer sa fait
pousser les grilles et donc on appelle
là en l'occurrence et la gendarmerie
mobile alala aux secousses mais pas à
chaque fois jean christophe couvent il
ya vraiment eu certaines images ou
littéralement des agents police c'était
après 80 dispositif anti émeute qui sont
allés aspergé le visage de certains
supporters bloqué derrière une grille
d'accords et vous il ya des images il ya
des images qui peuvent choquer je ne
suis pas là pour les dédouaner ou pas je
dise j'en parle et avec monsieur
non mais il peut y avoir des
comportements particuliers de
fonctionnaires de police qui n'aurait
peut-être pas dû mettre un coup de gaz
là où il ya la personne ne faisait rien
après attention il faut voir toutes les
images on en a mais on a bien compris
aussi des fois
l'idée c'était de que plusieurs
personnes s'agglutinent sur des
barrières à mon année les barrières est
en train de bouger donc les forces de
l'ordre aussi était un peu démunis et
ôté obligé préventivement dès fois de
temps en temps de mettre des petits
coups de jets de gaz pour éviter que les
personnes se rapproche des grilles moi
je suis pas là pour les défendre il ya
encore une fois je oui on n'est pas à
l'abri qui est un imbécile qui qui qui
qui profitent du système pour pour
mettre du gaz sur des
éléments de discernement mais ça n'a pas
été le cas je peux pas dire encore une
fois c'est pas la police c'est peut-être
le fait de un policier mais un policier
n'est pas la police patrick mignon quel
regard vous portez le sociologue que
vous êtes sûr sur les scènes de samedi
soir est ce que ses propres au football
bah on va s'accorder pour dire que oui
oui et à ses propres au football même si
on avait ici des grecs ou des turcs eux
qui nous dirait que les matchs de basket
athènes ou à istanbul sont pas d'un
calme absolu voilà bon donc c'est mais
globalement si on fait là si on reprend
l'histoire récente
quoi qu'est ce qui le sport qui
accompagnait de mouvements de troupes de
désordre parce qu'il y avait eu samedi
sur le stade de france il y avait hier
soir d'être est celle où ces gens
là sont première de la première league
cette année fin de la ligue 1 a été
assez
assez alimenté par par une chronique des
désordres donc voilà ça c'est ça c'est
certain ce qui à mon avis est enfin fait
peut-être partie du problème de
deux qu'on veut discuter ces terres que
certaine façon organisée et en france
peut-être plus qu'un autre pays les pays
qui nous entourent le football est un et
1 est un problème
parce que parce que justement il a 7 il
a fait quoi si passionné parce que ben
oui trop passionné en même temps oui et
non je veux dire cependant du duo poule
est très passionné mais celui qui était
là samedi il était bon plutôt bon enfant
alors on peut être passionné bon enfant
enfin pas nécessairement non non c'est
faire ça attire beaucoup de monde
s'était beaucoup de monde tout à l'heure
j'entendais la formule le football n'est
pas qu'un sport c'est la société etc de
fait j'ai ri les très très hétérogène
dans ces publics est un sport populaire
ça reste aussi un sport scolaire très
populaire même si on fait plutôt moins
qu'ailleurs mais bon il reste en france
le sport le plus populaire le plus
pratiqué dans les clubs celui qui attire
les plus grands d'audience à la
télévision d'accord avec monsieur mine
parce que on dit c'est le football qui
pose problème non non le football n'est
que le reflet des problèmes de société
et c'est là où je suis pas d'accord avec
vous c'est parce que
parler vous parlez du club vous avez
évoqué le club isme effectivement il ya
des bastons entre supporteurs de
l'étoile rouge et du partisan à belgrade
autour des matchs de foot mais aussi
autour des matches de basket et la même
chose entre l'olympiakos et le
panathinaïkos en grèce donc en fait
c'est l'attachement à un club la passion
autour d'un club qui provoque
effectivement des comportements
exacerbée mais parfois voulu on défend
il ya cet attachement cet esprit de
clocher qui fait que parfois on va se
bagarrer sur les parkings avant les
matches et le cas par exemple aux pays
bas avant les derbys entre le foyer nord
de rotterdam et l'ajax d'amsterdam donc
ce sont des faits de société qu'on peut
déplorer mais je crois qu'il faut pas
mettre dans le même sac comme vous
l'avez fait
saint-etienne et le stade de france
samedi soir saint-etienne s'est
effectivement depuis plusieurs semaines
voire plusieurs mois le désarroi du
peuple vert face à un club qui a été mal
géré face à des choix sportifs qui ont
été catastrophiques et le club qui
descend en d2 sur un penalty manqué par
ryad boudebouz parce que finalement il
jusqu'au bout ils ont eu l'espoir de se
maintenir la samedi soir au stade de
france on est devant un défaut
d'organisation est face à un problème de
société qui est lié à des des petites
frappes de banlieue qui sont venus
dépouiller les supporters du real ou du
ou duo de liverpool ado c'est un
problème d'organisation liés à ces faux
à ces faux billets donc on est on est
dans deux cas bien différent et
qu'ensuite on mais on est tous dans le
même sac on met sur le dos du football
mais il faut voir tous les matchs qui se
déroule très bien tout au long de la
saison et dans lesquels n'y a pas de
problème tous les week-ends vous avez
des centaines d'hommes des des milliers
de matchs en france et heureusement y'a
pas des problèmes à tous les matchs au
contraire même le foot canalise beaucoup
la halle à l'énergie d'un certain nombre
de jeunes et quand ils sont sur le
terrain en train de jouer au foot qui
sont pas en train de faire deux choses
malgré mignon ça veut dire que vous
faites une distinction entre ce que vous
appelez le clovis n'attache mans un club
et parfois quand il ya des des
rencontres aussi importante soit elle
mais entre sélections nationales voulais
lui dire qu'une autre chose sous l'effet
que de façon générale la ici c'est quoi
le problème de
le prime de samedi le samedi bon ya un
problème d'organisation six
organisations et je dis qu'en france
particulièrement le football est un
problème parce que étant populaire les
acteurs qui sont censés s'occuper de la
gestion du football aussi bien en termes
sportifs la fédération serbe de football
au niveau de l'uefa en
termes d'ordre public c'est à dire à ce
moment là c'est là l'état et la police
et les clubs ont été rappelés les clubs
et du côté la fédération et les
supporters il ya quelque chose qui ne
fonctionne pas et qui ne fonctionnent
pas depuis les années 80 certes depuis
le moment
médiatisation du football donc plus
grande popularité des clubs
souvenir de quelques épopée de club jean
saint-etienne dans les années
précédentes mon remontée de l'équipe de
france fait du football quelque chose
qui était beaucoup plus populaires
appâter le soin qu'il l'était auparavant
vers des audiences étaient des visions
et si pas beaucoup de monde dans les
stades en tout cas une mobilisation des
supporters et en toile de fond vous avez
tout ce qui se passe en angleterre tout
ce qui se passe en langue tout ce qui se
passe en italie qu'il a effectivement
est beaucoup plus sérieux et je dirais
en france globalement je dis c'est une
question que je poserai à
d'autres fermetures excuse moi j'ai peur
qu'il ne vaut un chef du peu sourd donc
sur effectivement là le fait que la
borde un match de football d'un grand
événement de football va se faire avec
un état d'esprit avec des présupposés
qui sont pas ceux qu'on aura quand on a
quand on va regarder un match de rugby
quand on regarde un match de rugby où
les jeux olympiques c'est ça que je
voulais dire en disant qu'il ya un
problème en poings liés au football
d'organisation diniz qui n'est pas
rassurant dans la perspective de
certains grands événements où on va
simplement rapidement écouté la ministre
des sports qui revenait sur ce problème
d'organisation et xavier barret je vous
redonne la parole
des world difficulté
il y a eu des difficultés dans la façon
dont nous avons géré les flux nous ne
voulons pas dire que nous avons tout
bien fait clairement pas mais ce que
nous disons c'est qu'il ya eu un
concours de circonstances qui a rendu
les choses difficiles la grève dans les
transports
il est tardive et aussi le fait que nous
ne savions pas que nous n'étions pas
capables de vraiment localiser les gens
qui arrivaient au stade de france il n'y
avait pas de trajet claire entre la fan
zone et le stade pas de bus organisés et
caetera et là dessus c'était très
différent de ce que le real madrid a
organisé pour ses supporters
xavier c'est un problème d'organisation
ce n'est pas notre responsabilité ce que
disent en substance les deux minutes
près mais ils ont tort parce qu'il ya
quand même un président de la république
qui s'est battu pour avoir cette finale
de la ligue des champions au stade de
france c'est quand même sa fiche précise
a dû être organisé très rapidement parce
qu'elle devait initialement se tenir à
ses intérieurs ce bourg à la gazprom
arena donc dans un stade qui est
directement liée effectivement aux
affaires de monsieur poutine et de son
entourage ça veut dire qu'on n'avait pas
les moyens finalement de l'accueillir
cette finale on a eu rétention supérieur
à ce qu'on pouvait bien sûr qu'on avait
les moyens après il fallait peut-être
faire des choix on veut vous cache pas
que vous cache pas qu'on ait aussi en
période électorale donc il y a des
moments ça c'est mon voisin qui pourrait
mieux en parler que moi mais mais il ya
en période électorale ça fait désordre
si par hasard il ya des jeunes qui sont
tabassés que ça passe en vidéo etc donc
il est probable que les forces de
l'ordre n'est pas pu employer tous les
moyens qu'il fallait pour sécuriser la
zone après il ya effectivement le
phénomène des supporters de liverpool et
liverpool est un club extrêmement
populaire leurs supporters se déplacent
moi je me souviens en 2005 à istanbul
pour la finale d'istanbul s'était plus
loin que paris ils sont venus et même
les supporters de milan qui est à
istanbul revendait leur place parce que
effectivement les anglais sont une vraie
passion pour le football les supporters
des verts sont capables de traverser
l'europe pour aller supporter leur
équipe et donc il est prêt à confirmer
iman al fahm un prêt à payer beaucoup
d'argent moi j'étais désolé pour eux ces
gamins que j'ai vues dont les parents se
saignent pour leur payer un billet qui
arrivent et qui se retrouve derrière les
grilles volés par des gens malhonnêtes
d'aider des jeunes des quartiers autour
du stade de france parce que ils n'ont
pas pu rentrer ils n'ont pas pu offrir
ça à leurs gamins c'est lamentable ils
ont brisé le rêve de milliers de gamins
et ça c'est vraiment choquant qu'il ya
un problème de compréhension de la façon
dont le football et vécu en angleterre
par rapport à la façon dont le football
et vécu en france ou ailleurs en europe
d'ailleurs quoi c'est un problème
culturel clairement clairement parce que
le supporter de ne pas seulement aux
supporteurs de liverpool mais le
supporteur anglais le supporteur
britannique se déplace peu importe le
moyen pour ce pur qu'il va trouver pour
se déplacer il va se déplacer je peux
comprendre que pour la police ça peut
poser ça puisse poser problème que je
comprends aussi que pour les
institutions publiques que ce soit
exactement la même chose mais le
supporter on va se déplacer de la
manière meilleure façon qu'ils trouvent
de le faire cissé on prend la voiture
depuis liverpool pour traverser la
manche avec le ferry est arrivé à paris
il fera s'il doit prendre l'avion qui
arrivait à bruxelles pour ensuite
descendre en quarts à paris il fera
s'il doit alors justement parce qu'il ya
des passions que la part des supporters
parce qu'ils sont prêts à faire des
kilomètres pour suivre leur équipe est
ce qu'il aurait pu y avoir un trafic de
faux billets en angleterre c'est en
substance ce que disait en tout cas le
ministre français de l'ariège vous donc
celle enquête est en cours moi je serai
il ya non mais mon voisin
sûrement plus qualifiés que moi pour en
parler mais c'est vrai qu'il ya une
telle passion en angleterre et même au
delà puisque il ya les glasgow rangers
c'est pareil il était en davy pour la
finale de la ligue europa lille il ya
dix jours ils y sont allés à 50 milles
alors qu'ils avec 20000 places est
d'ailleurs leinster francfort c'était la
même chose et on n'a pas eu ccsn il ya
eu quelques bagarres effectivement à
séville mais n'y a pas eu ces scènes de
désolation qu'on a pu apercevoir au
stade de lyon si je trouve extrêmement
dommage aussi que que l'on que lanson
tête à
un mètre au code les supporteurs de
liverpool qui se déplace son billet
l'objectif est que l'on clown accuse
notamment
le manager de liverpool jürgen klopp
d'avoir dit aux supporteurs de se
déplacer moi même j'étais à madrid pour
la finale dès 2019 j'avais pas de billet
mon objectif ce n'était pas d'acheter un
billet parce que je n'avais pas les
moyens d y avait une zone aussi on
plaque c'est d'ailleurs l'objectif
c'était d'aller dans la fanzone de le
profiter avec mes amis qui avaient fait
le déplacement également et c'était tout
le but tout l'objectif que j'avais dans
ce déplacement là profitez fêter passer
un bon moment avec mes amis est fêtée à
ce moment là je l'espérais le titre on a
fait c'est comme ça que ça s'est passé
et à madrid il n'y a pas eu de problème
donc accuser les supporteurs qui se
déplacent hommage aux masses jeu le
court je l'entends je l'entends mais il
n'est pas là le problème à madrid il y
avait je sais plus combien de centaines
de milliers de supporters qui se sont
déplacés pour un stade de 90 mille
places aux 40 milk et 80000 places et il
n'y a pas eu ces problèmes-là j'entends
que l'on veuille se débarrasser du
problème je l'entends mais c'est mon
opinion très personnelle ce mais le
problème ne passe pas par là il ya une
incompréhension absolu de la façon dont
culturelle dans les onglets vivre c'est
vrai qu'en france on a encore l'image du
à izel c'est vrai il faut le dire qui
c'est passé en 1985 cette finale à à
bruxelles où il y avait eu 38 ou 39 de
l'homme de se rendre compte du besoin
côté supporters lyonnais mus par une
charge de hooligans de liverpool mais
depuis il faut rappeler une chose c'est
que madame thatcher avait pris des des
règles extrêmement strictes pour mettre
un terme à ces phénomènes de
hooliganisme en angleterre que les clubs
anglais ont été suspendues pendant cinq
ans des coupes européennes et liverpool
pendant six ans c'est à dire pendant
cinq ans les a plus vus sur la scène
européenne liverpool pendant six ans de
façon à apurer tout tout c'est toutes
ces dérives et qu'aujourd'hui vous allez
dans les stades en angleterre il ya il
ya des problèmes de temps en temps mais
ça reste exceptionnel
et de toute façon dans l'est dans le
championnat national aujourd'hui tout
est a pris tellement de valeur à l'image
des droits télé les places sont devenues
tellement cher que les gens des milieux
très populaire qui peut parfois
nourrissait cccc bande de hooligans
aujourd'hui se retrouvent dans les pubs
parce qu'ils ont plus les moyens d'aller
au stade donc ce phénomène là qui a
évoqué monsieur mignon et qui existait
dans les années 80 et et aujourd'hui
devenu très marginale donc les
supporters anglais qui viennent sont
d'abord des gens passionnés de foot et
qui viennent pacifiquement patrick
mignon voulez réagir à ce que dit xavier
barret oui oui non mais toutes deux tout
à fait et vers la la le point que
quelques été soulevée c'est le point sur
effectivement c'est ça la question
prenantes qu'au coin qui est pendante 1
et qui fait qu'on peut pas ne pas relier
les événements de du soir avec les
événements de la veille et les éléments
de l'avant veille etc c'est
qu'effectivement l'alleud la question
qui se pose même si c'est des équipes
qui n'étaient pas l'équipe française
mais séance patrons français sait pas
c'est que c'est la question qui se pose
c'est de savoir comment en france on
peut d'une manière alors soit identique
à la grande-bretagne enfin l'angleterre
soit identique soit de manière similaire
à celle qui se passe en italie ou en
espagne ou en allemagne trouver des
moyens qui fâchent qu'effectivement on
est pour des événements de ce type d je
dirais en quelque sorte d'aider des
réflexes ce que pour moi il me semble
leur effet quand si c'est à dire c'est
les sortant de leur poule parce
qu'effectivement une époque là les
hooligans notamment nourrissait leur
caisse avec les faux billets mais dire
les chefs hooligans étaient aussi des
trafiquants de faux billets voilà un il
est fabriqué à l'époque c'est pas dit
s'il n'y avait pas de qr code est pas de
choses comme ça donc c'était plus facile
de faire marcher l'imprimante même donc
c'est ce phénomène existe mais la
question qui se pose ici c'est
effectivement celle qui consiste à à
faire revenir à la surface ces souvenirs
du fou du supporters anglais de du coup
lui mettre sur le dos des choses qui
sont fausses et est la question qui est
celle de savoir qu'est ce que nous en
france on fait quand on a des supporters
quand on a des tensions dans les stades
qui s'occupe de cette affaire et là
effectivement l'angleterre une réponse
la manade une réponse la france pour moi
n'a pas donné de réponse elle a laissé à
donner à paris en matière à s'inquiéter
encore une fois je leur est
victime de deux événements importants
qui vont se dérouler ici le mondial de
rugby les jeux olympiques de paris en en
2024 jean christophe coubris comment
est-ce que les forces de l'ordre se
prépare en prenant note de ce qui s'est
passé au stade de france à saint-etienne
dans une autre mesure encore une fois
que vous avez marre et je les ai noté
mais comment est ce que vous vous
préparer d'après ce qui s'est passé là
est-ce qu'il va falloir repenser tout le
dispositif sécuritaire est la réponse
que doivent rapporter les forces de
l'ordre dans des situations telles telle
qu'on l'a connue déjà une petite
parenthèse on sait organiser des grands
moments de sport on a fuit la coupe du
monde 98 on a fait la coupe d'europe
2016 on est capable quand même voilà on
a déjà eu une coupe du monde de rugby
aussi fin on est quand même capable de
gérer des grands événements la
terre qui était salie le en le en
juillet à wembley la finale de la coupe
d'europe contre l'italie justement il ya
le même problème c'est qu'il y avait des
anglais qui sont entrés illégalement
dans le stade qui avait des faux billets
aussi qu'ils sont battus avec la police
les stadiers enfin avec les stadiers et
la police est d'ailleurs née été
dépassée complètement et je me rappelle
les tabloïds anglais 10 est une honte et
un désastre parce qu'en visu les anglais
veulent avoir la coupe du monde 2030 et
là ils sont dit ça y est c'est carottes
on pourra pas l'avoir mais on a vu
l'image les la razor ramon mais la
réponse de la police n'est pas la même
qu'en france jean christophe riblon
supporter comme supporteur britannique
vous disent par exemple pourquoi est ce
que la police française dégaine tout de
suite des gaz lacrymogènes je ne sais
pas s'il vous confirmer ce qui a été dit
par d'autres supporters rodolfo amaya
mais il ya parfois une possibilité de
dialogue de discussion est ce qu'il n'ya
pas une particularité française est ce
que peut-être les consignes qui sont
données à l'échelle supérieure les
colons les consignes justement non une
défend les attend les consignes aussi
c'est à dire que policière comment ça se
passe dans une situation comme ça c'est
qu'on l'a déjà on a une force de
maintien de l'ordre donc on avait des
gendarmes mobiles avait lui même confié
me l'a peu près on était sept mille 7000
pour tout paris parce qu'elle est fan
zone aussi à surveiller donc dans le
xiième et aux alentours du stade et les
gens qu'on avait défendu un peu partout
parce qu'on sait que des petits groupes
qui vont se balader les groupes de
supporters enfin quand on reçoit
un afflux de 80000 personnes ou voire
même 100 me avec tous les personnes
forcément on sait que paris on est
encore plus vigilants que d'habitude et
vous avez des renseignements en amont
qui vous permet d'être
déployée sur tel ou tel site par ex bien
sûr on essaie de quadriller on essaie
d'anticiper et les choses des choses
qu'on ne maîtrise pas et d'ailleurs les
choses qu'on n'a pas maîtrisé c'était
justement la problématique aiguë dans
les prés filtrage et la grève aussi du
rer b qui a permis qui a empêché d si
vous voulez ça empêché les supporters
d'aller y avait 34 points d'entrée et en
fait à empêcher les supporters de tous
se déplacer de prendre des portes
d'entrée donc tout le monde sait qu à
gueuler sur une ou deux portes d'entrée
et ce qui a créé donc à noah d'étayage
un goulot d'étranglement et d'ailleurs
abandonné si les policiers sur place qui
ont dit il faut qu'on ouvre les
barrières parce qu'il y avait des gens
qui commençaient à être compressé qui
souffrent et qui tombe et keven et
malaise ils ont fait sauter le bouchon
rdc où ils ont pris cette décision
la donne est quelque part c'est la
police on a des romans ont fait des
remontées on dit là il faut faut enlever
ça c'est pas écouté la preuve c'est
qu'on a on a ouvert sa alors qu'en fait
cette année même c'est un événement
privé mais donc on a pris l'initiative
de dire bon stock maintenant on arrête
on ouvre et c'est à partir de là
effectivement j'ai à dire que le marasme
à commencer c'est à dire c'est à partir
de là qu'il ya aussi des bandes
de 2,2 saint-denis du 93 des francs
moisins à côté et et ailleurs qui sont
aussi infiltrés ce à partir de là moi
j'ai vu des images où il ya des gamins
qui soit arraché leur billet qui ont
leur billet dans les mains et qui se
font arracher par des petites frappes
qui partent en courant pour les revendre
derrière ou aller au stade ouais moi ça
me navre tout ça voilà parce que c'est
pas l'image qu'on veut donner de la
france quand il ya des gens qui viennent
pour une fête je suis désolé on à
l'accueil français et là on les a pas
accueillie comme il fallait voilà et
c'est en tant que policier nos collègues
nous le disait quand on voyait parce que
quand on est en maintien de l'ordre et
qu'on est obligé de garder là si vous
voulez le garder la
stabilité du du 2-2 tout l'environnement
à maintien de l'ordre en fait vous avez
des unités qui sont un peu composé par
tous il faut rester là où on est parce
que si vous partez ça déséquilibre tout
donc il faut rester et quand vous voyez
à 50 mètres des des gens qui sont
dépouillés qui soit interpellé attaquez
vous n'intervenez on peut pas intervenir
sauf sur instruction alors là ce qui
nous a manqué c'est des forces mobiles
d'intervention des bacs
par exemple des bacs civile des
collègues du terrain des bac
départementale et qui arrive qui
interpelle qui casse les petits groupes
et qui les a été mis en place la bonne
question c'est je pense qu'on manquait
aussi d'effectifs mobile la moitié des
forces mobiles engagé sur paris je suis
désolé de le dire mais fait des
servitudes cirque acer sert à protéger
beauvau et l elysée
comment il ya peut-être un problème à en
donner de savoir ce qu au monde
utilisent des forces de police voilà
est-ce que les forces de police font
mieux les utiliser sk on en il faut
donner les tâches de servitude plutôt à
des effectifs locaux sur paris est
plutôt utilisé des crs et compagnie
c'est de républicaines de sécurité qui
doivent intervenir des matches comme ça
y est c'est le job il ya justement des
réactions politiques ans on va écouter a
tout de suite jean luc mélenchon qui
revenait justement sur la réorganisation
des forces de l'ordre lors d'événements
comme celui ci on les écoute il doit y
avoir une réflexion de fond pour
remettre la police française dans un
dispositif qui la rendent efficace ça
c'est pas efficace si vous voulez leur
rôle n'est pas et on peut m'être donné
plein d'excusés on a des supporters
violents les faux billets etc mais le
rôle de la police c'est d'empêcher que
ça tourne mal
or là c'est le contraire ils ont aggravé
les choses un sentiment d'humiliation
parce que nous sommes regardés par le
monde entier et l'intégralité je crois
des capitales qui ont vu cela on
constatait que la france et n était plus
dans la capacité d'organiser de grandes
manifestations sans que ceux-ci dégénère
en partie par une désorganisation dont
il faudra que les organisateurs
s'explique et puis en partie par une
délinquance traditionnelle classique
maintenant qui a fait qu'à chaque
événement est bien celui ci se
transforment en émeute se transformant
en tentatives de pillage jean-christophe
couvy d'abord ce problème de rôles pas
assez efficace moi je réponds à monsieur
mélenchon la police aggraver les choses
en la police a pas aggraver les choses
c'est juste que déjà c'est une personne
qui s'ils arrivent un jour au pouvoir
aussi et premier ministre va supprimer
les bacs donc je disais brigade
anticriminalité on en a besoin et veut
désormais les les forces mobiles en
supprimant des moyens d'intervention les
gaz lacrymo les grenades de
désencerclement les bd etc
c'est que c'est que nous on sait pas
comment faire sans pour l'instant la
désescalade repensez votre formation non
il faut la légère la formation faut la
continuer c'est pas ça le problème le
problème c'est que enfin ce monsieur
nous donne des leçons alors qu'en fait
lui même il serait pas comment faire bon
mais mais on voit bien que la
désescalade par exemple si on avait
utilisé la désescalade comme les pays
également comme les pays suède obtient
la suède etc
on aurait laissé les choses cirque les
policiers seraient pas intervenus et
donc on aurait ouvert les portes du
stade eh bien on aurait eu des milliers
de personnes qui se relaient dans le
stade c'est ça la désescalade ce cas où
on est on laisse le terrain et en france
on a l'habitude dans le maintien de
l'ordre de ne pas laisser le terrain
c'est comme ça c'est c'est notre façon
de faire on voit les suédois d'ailleurs
qui ont eu aussi des émeutes urbaines ya
pas longtemps ils sont en train de nous
contacter pour nous demander comment on
peut comment vous vous y vous utilisez
des armes intermédiaires parce que nous
on est démuni et on est démuni devant
cette nouvelle violence urbaine est en
fait toutes les vingt ans qu'on a sur la
désescalade sur la façon de faire du
maintien de l'ordre en fait on se rend
compte que ça ne sert plus rien et donc
ils sont en train de regarder le modèle
français voilà on en est toujours fermée
m la désescalade comme de l'appeler
c'est à dire vers l'est ouvrir les
portes du stade pour que tout le monde
puisse entrer c'est ce qui a amené le
drame de hillsborough
en angleterre 1989 exactement où 97
personnes sont mortes écrasées
ou encore par la suite des des blessures
qu'ils ont qu'ils ont subi je ne pense
pas que ce soit une solution jeu
je me souviens d'être allé plusieurs
plusieurs fois en angleterre et
il ya un respect énorme du policier et
un respect énorme deux policiers et un
respect énorme du steward du de les
stadiers qui nous disent en aiguille qui
vous montrez nous dit simplement assieds
toi assieds toi assieds toi la prochaine
fois tu es dehors hélas ces
interdictions de stade cc c'est simple
ce que vous êtes en train de dire c'est
qu'il ya une autorité un peu plus
affirmée de l'apport des stewart mais
aussi clé les supporteurs respecte
davantage ce qu'on était beaucoup plus
de dialogue déjà les gens en général
sont plus respectueux en angleterre
quand vous allez poursuivre un brunch
day le 11 novembre à londres 11 heures
pétantes toute la circulation s'arrête
les gens s'arrêtent dans la rue et
respecte les minute de silence en
souvenir des anciens qui sont morts
pendant la guerre 14 18 en france le 11
novembre il se passe plus rien depuis
longtemps non mais c'est un exemple
parmi les autres donc donc si vous
réagissez quand vous le souhaitez un oui
oui le
jeu revient sur la question de la bonde
l'est effectivement les cours nationales
sont la culture nationale voilà ce
qu'elles sont et donne par exemple donne
certes un certain type de produit en
angleterre
c'est effectivement respect de la police
mais je me souviens quand on travailler
avec des collègues enfin policiers et
travailleurs sociaux et cetera soit les
questions de violence dans les stades il
y avait une clause qui était ressortie
était qu'il y avait une sorte de deux
comme ça de deux mots d'ordre de la
police anglaise qui étaient les trois
les 3f
3ème femme
faire justin shawn lee amical on traduit
qui signifie ce qui signifie une chose
c'est qu'effectivement on doit
mesurer
les différentes polices par rapport en
quelque sorte à une des espèces comme
sein de 2,2
pas de mot d'or mais de principes qui
gouvernent leur relation à la population
alors ce qui n'empêche pas en angleterre
de temps en temps on a aussi eu des
munitions très dur quand il veut déminer
grèves de mineurs en angleterre et la
police a pas été tous avec les avec les
mineurs mais jansen façon globalement
c'est cette espèce c'est cet ensemble si
on reprend la question de la désescalade
dans le cas de l'allemagne
qu'effectivement qui était une stratégie
qui était mise en place à l'époque des
grèves contre les comptes contrôle et
notamment les les convois de 2,2 de
matières nucléaires et des missions très
violente bon on a mis en place et des
bouquins ce principe d escalade le
principe étant que si les forces de
l'ordre monte en puissance autre côté on
va faire aussi monter la tension donc on
emploie des moyens plus fort mais on
trouve aussi d'autres moyens pas
seulement vers des moyens si on veut
militaire au sens technique du terme des
tenues des stratégies serra mais on a
aussi on rentre aussi dans décidant des
stratégies de dialogue et de
communication
par exemple bon ce qui a été appliqué
dans le cas du football aussi bien dans
le cas d' angleterre que dans le cas de
l'allemagne alors la question que moi je
me pose cette ccsl à sûr il ya un
problème d'emploi des forces de l'ordre
notamment elles sont à utiliser et tout
doux c'est fernand le football on a eu
tendance pourra repartir et des
commissions et la ligue de football a
considéré que c'était pas problème des
clubs de s'occuper des supporters donc
on laisser ça à la police et cetera bon
après il ya eu des mouvements tout mais
la vraie question c'est de savoir à quel
principe obéit lusage lutter à ce qu'on
va faire
des policiers à mais entend les faits
alors on pourrait bien me semble pour
franche et pas à eux
policiers bashing comme diraient
certains
ça correspond aussi ça correspond aussi
une sainte femme d'expérience du rapport
du rapport à la police donc comment
est-ce qu'on commence convient souvenez
vous discuterez à plus de proximité et
je vais relégation le stade de france le
stade de france vous pouvez imaginer
aussi que le stade de france qui est
construit en plein milieu d'une des
banlieues les plus populaires sur
effectivement autour c'est des bureaux
mais ne sont pas loin les cités
effectivement c'est un pôle d'attraction
extraordinaire donc normalement c'est un
endroit où
une police des acteurs connaissent un
réacteur locaux pourrait non seulement
intervenir de façon dure pour retirer
des délinquants mais aussi parce que ils
connaissent les gens et ils sont
capables aussi de mettre à l'écart
d'empêcher des tensions qui montent
voilà c'est tout c'est des choses comme
ça ou de hockey l'on
construit en 98 à l'époque on avait une
autre image c'était black blanc beur un
chemin en appel c'était voilà la
concorde nationale et c'était très bien
c'était bien choisi fin je pense que
j'en remets pas en question sauf
qu'entre temps mais à dupont enfin il ya
de l'eau qui a coulé sous les ponts on
voit bien maintenant que la société
quand même de plus en plus violente
aussi le côté football c'est vrai qu'en
france on n'a pas le même rapport au
football comme en angleterre le football
en angleterre c'est une religion mais
c'est vrai moi j'ai vécu deux ans à
newcastle j'étais étudiant et j'ai vu
que là bas les gens le samedi quand il
joue et c'est toute une ville qui porte
les couleurs du club c'est
impressionnant on peux pas le décrire en
france ils vivent pour ça ils ont des
draps des draps aux couleurs de leur
club ils tout et tout et aux couleurs du
club ont donc ça c'est on sent que c'est
une vraiment une religion il ya un
respect il ya un respect aussi pour le
bobbies le bobby angle il ya un respect
parce que c'est très anglo-saxon parce
qu'on sait que là-bas le bobby il est
sacralisé aussi on touche à la police on
va faire de la prison ferme
on a des bagarres dans des dents des on
commet des exactions dans l'est dans les
stades on va être interdit de stade à
vie là j'ai en mémoire un français cassé
à marseille je crois ou à nice qui lance
une bouteille sur la tête d'un joueur de
paillettes bon il a pris cinq ans est
encore voilà mais en angleterre le mec
ne met plus jamais les pieds dans un
stade terminé sauf que nous en fait on
est un peu fébrile par rapport à sa
politique pénale qu'il faut rien avait
un premier avait juste un rappel à la
loi je crois et ensuite un appel qui a
été fait il me sembla là parce que sa
démission était dérisoire mais mes skis
a pas aussi un problème vis-à-vis des
supporters xavier bommart et si je me
trompe mais je crois que lily à
certaines interdictions déplacements de
supporters le port du maillot de
certains supporters avait été interdite
sous peine d'amendés donc est ce qu'il
n'ya pas aussi un problème vis-à-vis des
supporters surtout après deux années
qu'ovide de frustration peut-être de de
pouvoir marquer c'est vrai qu'on a eu
d'aidé d'un an et demi sans supporters
dans les stades et que quand ils sont
revenus on était content parce que moi
pour avoir fait plan de match au parc
des princes notamment dans un stade vide
c'est un peu désolant donc effectivement
les stades sont faits pour être remplie
de supporters pas de voyous mais de
supporters et donc du coup quand ils
viennent parfois il ya de la passion il
ya sa chambre un peu aussi entre
supporters donc il peut y avoir des
débordements il y en a eu plusieurs sets
cette saison il y en a eu entre lille et
lens il ya eu entre l'om à l'om à angers
où il se passe jamais rien eu des
problèmes arranger il faut quand même le
faire bon nice om bien sûr mais là c'est
plus habituel une vraie rivalité donc
donc ce qui se passe le plus simple
souvent c'est que c'est les préfets de
les préfectures les préfets des deux
départements qui prennent la décision
d'interdire la venue des supporters
adverses et dans ces cas-là il ya
souvent des supporters qui viennent
quand même mais il faut pas qu'ils
mettent les couleurs de leur équipe
sinon ils sont arrêtés effectivement par
la police ou par la gendarmerie qui les
empêchent d'accéder au stade donc
parfois ils y vont en général quand ils
viennent entre guillemets j'allais dire
camoufler ça se passe plutôt bien
l'autre fois au parc des princes qui
est-ce qui est venu c'est tennis je
crois il y avait normalement pas de
supporters adverses il s'est trouvé
qu'il y avait il y avait quand même
quelques su quelques poches de
supporters qui sont restés calmes tout
le match et qui sont juste réveillé à la
fin ça s'est passé assez correctement ce
qu'il faut éviter effectivement c'est
les déplacements d'ultra dans ces cas là
parce que les ultras cherchent
l'affrontement cherche le défi et
parfois ça dégénère je voudrais avoir
aussi oui vous voulez intervenir patrick
mignon je vous en prie oui enfin c'est
simplement ses souhaits sur le un petit
peu le côté tout ou rien et un
bon pour avoir pour avoir assisté à
quelques sic qu'est ce que c'est que la
réception donc premièrement quand même
des choses qui nous le
si je prends le cas de l'allemagne là
la deutsche jugend la deutsche bahn
cheval à
un
jeu dira un service en relation avec la
fédération allemande de football pour
assurer l'équipement et supporters
donc supporters se déplacent en train en
allemagne alors quand vous voyez la ruhr
tout ça c'est fou tout ça se croise tous
les pans tous les dimanches c'est un
petit peu comme au tour de manchester et
de liverpool voilà et dans les villes ce
qui existe quand on reçoit les
supporters va à la gare et kerhuon
balaïa la police locale va la gare
rencontre les supporters qui ont
représentants ils ont moins formelle
avec qui on discute des conditions dans
lesquelles on va aller à la gare et il
ya un cortège qui se passe alors les
gens y avait des draps auto être comme
ça on va ostal avec la police qui est
dans un effectif et en tenue pas
extrêmement
martial leur duo fred un peu spéciale
pour le jour mais sans plus et va au
style et au style ils vont dans l'eure
alors ça on voit ça j'ai vu ça c'était
une dizaine d'années quand quand on
faisait les enquêtes sur le terrain et
sous les skis ce qu'est ce que ça
signifie c'est le travail en amont c'est
le travail en amont qui a été réalisé le
travail en amont qui consiste à dire
quand il ya un problème la première fois
ils apprennent dans le foot en allemagne
1 supporters d'un club croit que c'est
brême est tué par d'autres supporters
dans une bagarre le gouvernement
allemand les länder la police les clubs
et qu'est ce qu'on fait qu'est ce qu'on
fait c'est à dire qu'il réunion de crise
tout de suite pour essayer et on
travaille avec je ne sais pas pour faire
la pub pour les sociologues mon travail
avec les experts les gens qui ont une
connaissance du terrain et elle a
produit tuerie coût d'un point de vue
pratique ont réuni et on décide de faire
un plan national de sécurité penser à la
sécurité il comporte un volet qu'un
volet répressif on voit qu'il ya des
peines bas qui font qu'on interdit de
stades il ya des peines qui mérite la
prison etc il ya des interdictions par
rapport à certains types notamment il y
avait une grosse extrême droite à
l'époque donc une
le crâne boiteux virulent et stahl bon
un certain nombre de mesures pour
qu'elles pourraient le canaliser on met
en place des scènes de prévention socio
éducative alors il faut s'inspirer par
exemple du modèle allemand alors - et
non voilà avec les prochaines pluies
aggravées n'ont pas adopté tel quel mais
s'en inspirer dans le côté on prend les
choses au départ ont réuni à peu près
tout et qui ont concerné chacun prend
ses responsabilités
randall fois mais oui et
chacun prend ses responsabilités et puis
on partage de travail on voit comment
les choses évoluent et on fait des
bilans régulièrement donc eu des
changements pendant toutes ces années de
revenir est ce que vous disiez c'est
juste que je trouve extrêmement
intéressant
c'est ce type de déplacement se passe en
angleterre à l'intérieur du pays mais
encore une fois dès le moment où les
supports le supporteur anglais doivent
se doit se déplacer à l'étranger il va
trouver le meilleur moyen de se déplacer
et cela en un peu au détriment de ce que
vous venez de dire parce que ça peut
être par n'importe quel moyen il peut
arriver par la mer par le train par
l'avion et il n'y a pas vraiment un
moyen de les comptes de les contrôler et
c'est l'un des arguments du gouvernement
justement aujourd'hui ce que je trouve
encore plus dommage c'est que il y à une
doctrine une façon de faire et c'est aux
supporteurs de s'adapter alors que la
culture du supporterisme en angleterre
n'a strictement rien à voir avec la
culture protourisme
en france il ya quelques similarités
enfin pas d'enjeu d'espagne strictement
n'avoir qu' à quelques similarités nous
sommes bien d'accord mais on ne vit pas
de la même façon et donc si je dois me
déplacer pour mon équipe je vais le
faire
juste une chose puis
la question il nous reste trois minutes
que le par exemple on sait les fauteuils
de la poule on ne votait pas son grand
nombre on compte c'est
qu'elle est prêt à s'effacer comme ça
bon normalement tout le monde dans le
savoir un pan de la république le cei il
aime le foot il doit le savoir ça et
puis darmana je sais pas s'ils aiment le
foot mais il doit savoir aussi et le
pain de la fédé française doit savoir
aussi bon très bien donc qu'est ce qu'on
fait dans ces cas là qu'elles ont fait
dans ces cas là alors quelles sont les
informations dont on peut disposer dans
le pays d'où viennent ces supporters
pour pouvoir savoir qui vient comment ça
se passe et ce qui se passe au monde et
coupe du monde on les coupe du monde
coupe d'europe il ya des échanges par
exemple en ces circonstances là l'une
des questions que je me suis posée c'est
comment on tient compte dans les
dispositifs l'a envoyé dans le fait
qu'ils aient fait c'était rapide pour
s'organiser
mais qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est ce qu'on a
comme élément quel con et sur quels
éléments on s'appuie pour adapter
la façon dont on va mettre en place
toute l'organisation vous si bien enfin
guerre tout aussi bien de maintien de
l'ordre que que nous organisons et la
police de mercy sight faisait partie de
ce dispositif
ils étaient les seuls ils le font ils
font à chaque fois j'ai fait des
déplacements en europe avec liverpool
était villarreal gta à lisbonne j'ai eu
cette chance là j'étais à milan et les
personnes qui nous guide et à
l'intérieur du stade c'était des suppôts
des policiers anglais vous travaillez
mais toutes les polices européennes j'ai
à nous aussi on a des spécialistes voilà
qui suivent le football français et
quand il ya des déplacements comme ça on
prend des on prend attache avec la
police des polices étrangères et on
travaille de concert on ne pense pas
mais on se parle aussi dans les clubs on
se parle alors après en france
effectivement nous on laisse on laisse
la vision le j'allais dire la prise
d'initiative au club c'est au club de
faire le ménage dans ses supporters etc
à une époque c'est la police qui
rentrait dans les stades on n'a plus
voulu la police lundi notant la police a
rien à faire dans les stades et en plus
je le conçois mode c'est pas le rôle de
la police dans des stades à faire
stadiers donc on n'intervient que quand
il ya des problèmes donc en fait
effectivement c'est au club et on l'a vu
au pg à une époque c'était c'était
malsain le psg bombay on a mis le paquet
on a mis aussi à l'époque aux
renseignements généraux à paris il y
avait une section section hooligans on
l'avait appelé d'ailleurs et qui étaient
là pour justement créer du lien avec
avec les clubs de supporters les ultras
travailler avec eux négocier les tifos
les banderoles etc voilà tout il ya
toujours eu ce dialogue mais bon il nous
reste les cas second et leur
permettre de virer un certain nombre de
supporters parce que le stade est
toujours plein il ya même des gens en
attente pour avoir des abonnements alors
que dans les autres clubs et notamment
en province ils peuvent pas trop ils
peuvent au moins se permettre parce que
s'ils veulent remplir le stade ils ont
besoin de tout le monde donc il ya aussi
selon vous soyez riche ou pauvre le
comportement est un peu ce sera la fin
dans tous les cas il va falloir
absolument tirer les enseignements de ce
qui s'est passé samedi soir encore une
fois en perspective des futures
événements qui arrivent en france merci
à tous les quatre d'avoir accepté de
débattre sur le plateau de france 24
vous merci à vous de votre fidélité à
nos chaînes restent avec nous tout de
suite c'est raphaël cannes qui a le
plaisir de vous retrouver
[Musique]